hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my spoilery review of Avengers age of
Ultron with a breakdown of the Easter
eggs as well as an explanation for who
the new characters are I've already done
a non-spoilery review so if you're still
waiting to go see it you can still watch
that video I'll add a link for it in the
description so here we go careful for
spoilers I'm just gonna start with all
the really important stuff first like
how does this tie in with the other
phase 3 films how does it deal with the
Infinity Gauntlet Thanos all that stuff
so let's start with the mind gem first
that was actually the biggest surprise
of the film everyone was wondering if
that was the soul gem in visions 4head
because the soul gem is supposed to be
yellow as we've learned from the Marvel
films they've changed the colors of the
infinity gems from the comics and even
the comics contradict themselves during
Marvel's infinity event a couple years
ago the colors of the soul gems were
different from the classic jim Starlin
Thanos Infinity Gauntlet storyline so so
as you can see like no one can agree on
which colors the infinity gems need to
be the big T's of the post-credits
sequence is that Thanos is just gonna go
get the gems himself he's gonna stop
working through third-party agents we
don't know if he's gonna be in guardians
of the galaxy - that hasn't been
confirmed I'd expect to see him just a
little bit but because all of Thor's
visions had to do with the infinity gems
I definitely think that Thanos is gonna
show up in thor ragnarok that movie is
gonna be kind of like Thor's version of
Captain America Winter Soldier bringing
down an evil organization from the
inside we'll find out what kind of mess
Loki's made of Asgard I know a lot of
people are asking what happens if Thanos
rips the mind gem out of visions
forehead because he can't form the
Infinity Gauntlet without the mind gem
one it could kill him it could kill
vision like in the first infinity war
film - it can also be a way for Ultron
to come back because visions
consciousness is based on Ultron's
framework that could be the way the
Ultron comes back like parts of his
consciousness could reassert itself
inside vision I don't know if Ultron's
gonna come back during infinity war
think about how long ago the first
Captain America film was and how long
it's been since we've seen Red Skull
when Marvel puts a villain down they
they wait a while to bring them back
don't worry though Infinity Ward's gonna
be massive two-part film so you'll
probably see every Marvel villain you've
ever heard of so how does age of ultron
set up the other phase 3 films we saw if
Captain America Civil War we have
Captain Marvel black panther and the
Inhumans as we see at the end of the
there's a New Avengers training facility
in upstate New York with the New
Avengers team Tony Stark goes off says
he's going to create himself like a
Hawkeye style farm for Pepper Potts that
is very clearly a lie he's gonna go off
and work on some other secret project
the basis for civil war is just a little
bit different than the basis for civil
war in the comics when they made the big
phase 3 announcement they said the Civil
War disagreement would be based on who
reports to who who is in charge like who
holds the Avengers accountable in the
comics it's more about superhero
registration based on the on the impetus
of gun control agents of shield like the
last couple of episodes have made it
seem like they're weaving Inhumans into
that too like the idea of controlling or
registering super-powered people but
they'll probably do is they'll end up
combining that they change stuff you
know between announcements and actual
films all the time way back when Jon
Favreau was first making Iron Man they
went they went to comic-con and
announced the film they're like hey
we're gonna be making Iron Man with
Robert Downey jr. here they said that
the Mandarin was gonna be in the film
then obviously he did not end up in the
final cut of the film so you can see a
lot of things change from start to
finish so there might still be a lot of
the classic Marvel Civil War inside
Captain America Civil War so that's a
civil war what about Black Panther the
infer Black Panther is Ulysses Klaw he
explains he stole all that vibranium
from Wakanda losses and clearly they're
gonna follow up on that in the solo film
and in Black Panther is gonna be inside
Captain America Civil War so we'll
actually meet him see the costume for
the first time in that movie so age of
Ultron is just kind of a tease for Black
Panther Captain America Civil War we'll
set it up a lot more what about Captain
Marvel though Carol Danvers was actually
supposed to have a cameo in age of
Ultron but they cut her out at the last
minute Kevin Feige explained that they
shot the film intending to add her in
like you know that big fight sequence at
the end of the film when everyone was
flying around with war machine and
shield came back with Nick Fury they
would have added her into that part of
the film you know as well as like the
New Avengers facility but they decided
there were way too many characters in
the film it was already too bloated so
they just cut her out I'm kind of
expecting the same thing to happen with
Captain America Civil War like they'll
intend to put a bunch of characters in
there and just end up cutting him out at
the last minute because they find out
that there's too much stuff going on but
I do expect Carol Danvers to show up in
Civil War in some
Marvel isn't doing origin stories
anymore so in order to like tee up
characters they have to give them like
little tiny cameos and other films like
they spent age of Ultron setting up the
vision character so now they can roll
them out whenever they want and they
don't have to explain who he is they
don't have to do an origin story the
same things probably gonna happen with
Doctor Strange he'll probably have a
cameo and one of the other big films so
whenever we get to his film though just
the roll amount don't worry if you're a
big fan of origin stories they'll still
do back story in these solo movies just
not in the traditional way a really good
example of what they might end up doing
is daredevil episode 9 that's the no boo
episode where it opens with him fighting
him but then it jumps backwards and
forwards in time it's just a nonlinear
way to tell a story
so that's play how they're gonna convey
backstory in the future I know you're
asking about ant-man to like how does
this film get into ant-man because
technically a man is still a face to
film even though Avengers age of Ultron
is supposed to close down phase 2 it'll
pick up after age of Ultron and the
timeline and the decisions in the film
you know based on the ant-man and Yellow
Jacket suits the Pym particles will all
be based on the WTF stuff that happened
in age of Ultron that's really the only
explanation that Kevin Feige has given
but what about new characters in the
film there's all kinds of new characters
that this set up as well as some big
easter eggs like Jocasta so the Friday
Jocasta Easter Egg probably my most
favorite in the film you know aside from
vision picking up Thor's hammer so let's
start with his girl Friday in the film
Tony Stark loses Jarvis as his AI so he
creates more whenever he picks up the
Friday chip you actually see a chip
labeled Jocasta so it's almost like he
made a bunch of different AIS and he's
just picking and choosing the AI Friday
is actually a character from the comics
this debuted during the Iron Man
Protocol storyline in 2009 Pepper Potts
had stopped being Tony Stark's secretary
so instead of hiring a new human one he
decided to create one and called it his
girl Friday the name is a play on the
1940s Cary Grant movie called his girl
Friday where he plays a newspaper editor
trying to keep his ex-wife from
remarrying because he's still in love
with her the really funny thing about
the movie
the Joss Whedon did is that he took the
Jocasta Easter Egg and combined it with
the Cary Grant Easter Egg you can make
all kinds of jokes about Tony Stark
being in love with Jarvis but in the
comics the the Friday AI was more of a
Pepper Potts joke
in the movie it's more a play on what
happens with jocasta storyline in the
comics
Jocasta is literally his girl Friday who
Tony Stark Hank Pym and the Avengers are
trying to keep from marrying Ultron in
the comics so I'm just gonna explain a
little bit of Jocasta's back story in
the comics sheet-like vision was created
by Ultron so Ultron creates a new AI
called Jocasta to be his perfect bride
he names the character Jocasta after the
Greek tragedy of Oedipus that was the
guy that ended up marrying his mother
many levels to this many levels that's
why you had to love comic book writers
and Joss Whedon Ultron built Jocasta
using the brain patterns of the wasp
Janet Van Dyne Janet Van Dyne was kind
of his mother it's just that in the
comics Ultron was created by Hank Pym
who you know became his father he was
married to Janet Van Dyne who was kind
of like Ultron's mother he's creating a
bride in his mother's image just like
with the vision in the comics Jocasta
eventually turns against Ultron it joins
the Avengers I might actually have to do
a bonus video just for her at some point
because she has her own weird history in
the comics there was even this time
during Mighty Avengers where Jarvis
caught her kissing Hank Pym that's like
kissing her grandpa even though it's
possible that Ultron could come back
during infinity war I'm not expecting
them to do Jocasta at any point I think
it's gonna stay at the Easter Egg level
so moving down the list Helen Cho very
important in the movie big Easter Egg
for Amadeus Cho in the comics Helen Cho
in the movie is very different from
Helen Cho in the comics she was created
by Greg puck the same guy that went on
to write Planet Hulk even though she
debuted in Incredible Hercules her
storyline really only existed to serve
the development of Amadeus Cho as a
character Amadeus Cho was always the
more important character she was kind of
just like a secondary person because
she's so young in the movie if they do
end up doing Amadeus Cho in the film's
he'd have to be like her brother but but
the funny thing is in the movie is that
she's kind of secretly in love with Thor
so would it be awesome if Amadeus Cho
was born as the child of Thor and Helen
Cho the movie does give Helen Cho you
know a few things from the Amadeus Cho
character mostly his intelligence in the
comics he's like the seventh smartest
person on the planet in the movie Helen
Cho is like a genius biochemist who
creates the synthetic skin that Ultron
uses to 3d print vision I love the idea
that they use vibranium combined with a
3d bioprinter to create a new life for
I know there were a lot of questions
about how that worked like you know how
vision was created because it's a
combination of vibranium molecules
binding with the synthetic skin binding
with the mind gem it's like it's like a
whole bunch of stuff all at the same
time because they also added in Thor's
hammer with the lightning I also thought
of it as something of like a
Frankenstein myth just explain the
mechanics behind some of the visions
creation Helen Cho creates a synthetic
skin how Chi gets like a little bit of
it early in the film to cover up a wound
it's like biomatter that you can turn
into any type of tissue that you want
it's programmable biomatter think of it
as like SuperDuper stem cells vibranium
as Ultron explains is the most versatile
substance on earth that's why the
frisbee joke is so funny the most
versatile substance on earth and the
humans use it to make a frisbee
so when Ultron and Helen Cho bind the
vibranium with the synthetic skin
molecules they essentially they create
vibranium molecules that are infinitely
reprogrammable that's why vision is able
to alter his appearance it will like
what he creates the Thor cape why he
puts clothes on himself you guys can let
me know whether you agree not but I feel
like he saw Thor's cape and then that's
why he made his cape I just think that's
kind of funny especially since like
right after that he picks up Thor's
hammer
then there's the consciousness mixed
with the mine gem and Jarvis so that's a
little more complicated Ultron was
creating vision to just upload himself
into it was gonna be another Ultron bot
like an upgraded Ultron he only got
about halfway there till they put vision
in the body so the vision in the Ultron
parts kind of fought with each other so
when he added the mind gem it kind of
helped the Ultron vision bits fuse and
become something more what does that
mean something more well they kind of
leave that open to interpretation vision
has a soul whereas Ultron does not
that's why Scarlet Witch can read
visions mind that in the fact that a lot
of his body is alive
that's also because of the 3d printed
biomatter so mine gem Plus 3d biomatter
plus vibranium equals living machine the
difference between him and Ultron is
that Ultron is just like a hyper
intelligent AI walking around in a metal
body he doesn't have a soul there's no
biological aspect to his character I did
talk a lot about the origin story of
vision in the comics in like a top-five
Ultron stories video that I did so I had
a link for that in the description to
fun times with vibranium life-forms so
let's move
to ulysses klaw huge black panther
villain andy serkis most definitely
gonna reappear in the black panther solo
film his performance was one of the best
in the film he just like so funny yet so
brief I like the way he just threw shade
it's Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch
clearly you two are new at this I only
talked to the boss the movie basically
covers Ulysses claws backstory in a
casual turn of phrase claws explaining
to Ultron I acquired this vibranium at
great cost and chosen the tattoo that's
part of his origin story in the black
panther 2005 comic i know in the comics
he has a mechanical hand which plugin
happen is is you know because in the
movie ultron gives him billions of
dollars for the vibranium then chops his
hand off
Klaw is probably gonna use those
resources to create himself a vibranium
hand that's how we get to the claw in
ulysses klaw we also met dr. listen to
the movie but he's actually been on
agents of shield the last couple of
weeks he was one of the current heads of
Hydra he and Baron von Strucker both
died in the film so like the next step
down is Baron Zemo that's the character
while pricing Captain America Civil War
but that's only speculation so I don't
want to get too deep into that for those
asking about the missing characters like
Pepper Potts Jane Foster they're
essentially they're still in the MCU
but because Marvel doesn't want to use
them in the film's or doesn't need them
they're off on vacation or or managing
businesses and research projects that's
just like the blanket explanation hey
where's where's this big character oh
you know they're off they're off doing
some work so the story of vision Hawkeye
and Hulk kind of formed the moral core
of the film that's interleaved like the
action set-pieces the big fight scenes
then you have like the actual human
moments Joss Whedon owned up to the fact
that he's not very good at doing plot
he's really good with doing bits despite
any shortcomings he might have I feel
like the film did a good job of
balancing you know the big explosions
with the really personal moments even
though it's like the Hawkeye farm scenes
that form the backbone of the the human
aspect of the story I feel like they did
slip some stuff in in the big fight
scenes links of some really personal
human moments mostly via the Hulk and
Black Widow but it's Lynda Carter Nilla
here in hawkeye's relationship that
answers the question can Avengers have
normal lives like Bruce Banner has that
line when he's talking to Black Widow I
don't get any of this I don't get to
have this I think the question that the
film answers is that Avengers do get to
have normal lives just as long as
they're not Avengers you can also say
that they do get to have their you
their happy endings their normal lives
as they define it even though the Hulk
and the Black Widow have this really sad
ending you know I still feel like it
ends on a positive moment Captain
America's character is a good example
normal for him is the team he gets his
new team so even though he doesn't have
like his own Hawkeye farm off in the
distance with a wife he still has a
family that's really what the movie is
age of Ultron it's like a family therapy
session that last scene between vision
and Ultron 2 was one of the best in the
film and it's why I'm so excited to see
Paul Bettany play the vision in another
film a thing is not beautiful because it
lasts it paints a very grim picture for
Humanity in that vision says yeah
they're definitely doomed but it's such
an awesome way to end the film so as of
the end of the film these are the new
Avengers that we have going into Captain
America Civil War Captain America
leading the team vision Scarlet Witch
who probably gonna hook up at some point
Falcon and then Black Widow right now
we're still looking for the time gem and
the soul gem the soul gem probably gonna
show up during Doctor Strange just just
because of the way its powers work as
for the time Jim we might not see that
till infinity War part 1 because it
would have to involve time travel and we
haven't seen that into Marvel film yet
so here's my big question for you guys
well you know what was your favorite
part of the film you know vision picking
up Thor's hammer I really I think my
favorite part was the first time he
picked it up
even though him using it as a baseball
bat to hit Ultron was really cool too if
there are any specific bonus videos you
guys want me to do like Jocasta or
anything else for the other phase 3
films or characters just leave your
requests in the comments I did include a
bunch of extra links in the description
for other phase 3 movie videos that I've
done I think what I might do for my next
Marvel movie video is like favorite
times that different Avengers used other
Avengers weapons like Black Widow using
Captain America's shield Black Widow
even use Thor's hammer once I'll try to
post that sometime next week so be sure
to subscribe to get it if you haven't
seen it already you can actually click
here for my top 5 Ultron stories from
the comics and you can click here for
this week's agents of shield Avengers
crossover video thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you